pour assure tout va bien parce que le
fait de rouler et d'un château
mais ge et la magie de noël cette année
à envoyer les enfants au xviiie siècle
au temps de louis jean marie petit fils
de louis xiv contes et histoires fait
visiter les monuments nationaux
autrement c'est les anecdotes c'est
l'histoire de toutes ces personnes qui
ont vécu ici qui est importante et le
petit duc de penthièvre est né à
rambouillet et du coup c'est une partie
de lui qui est ici et c'est important de
faire vivre un petit duc éduqué par le
comte la leçon du jour est l'un des
contes les plus connus la belle et la
bête écrit par jeanne marie leprince de
beaumont mise en scène aujourd'hui par
une troupe et blinoise
vous n'êtes pas d'être venu on a été
soucieux de rester fidèle au texte à
l'auteur du xviiie siècle et est un
petit peu de redonner cette version
traditionnelle qui a complètement été
déformés avec le film qui est sorti
récemment ou encore le le dessin animé
qui est sorti il ya une vingtaine
d'années il ya un rythme lent il ya un
rythme très poétique
ça c'est vraiment ce qu'a voulu le
metteur en scène monique fonds didion
verdict à la sortie j'ai bien se méfie
aussi ont été atteints alors j'aime bien
ça et les costumes car il était assez
féerique lyon on ne saurait imaginer
dans la pièce pour cette troisième
édition de contes et histoires près de
450 personnes ont voyagé avec le petit
duc de penthièvre
[Applaudissements]